Fantastic. Well, um, thank
you Alex for over promising,
I hope to under deliver. Um, and thank
you everybody for being here today.
I'm really excited to be talking to
Google. Um, before I get started,
I just want to gauge where
the audience is. So, um,
if you have a background in physics,
like you've ever taken a course in quantum
mechanics, can you raise your hand?
Okay. So that's like maybe two
thirds, one half to two thirds.
It's good if you have no formal training
in physics and you just think that
quantum mechanics is cool or that physics
is interesting. Raise your hand. Okay,
good,
good.
So this talk is going to be aimed
primarily or at the level of people who
haven't taken any courses in quantum
mechanics, but at the end, in the Q and a,
we can get as technical as we want.
There's all sorts of stuff that
I'm not mentioning in his talk,
which we can get into in the Q and a.
So like if you are annoyed that I
don't mention decoherence for example,
we can talk about it in the Q and. A.
I can explain why I didn't mention it.
So let's talk about quantum physics.
Quantum physics is fantastic,
but there was a problem with it.
There's a hole at the heart of the theory.
And just to be clear, uh,
quantum physics works.
It works tremendously well. Uh,
it is by almost any measure,
the most successful scientific theory
that humanity has ever devised.
I had explains an enormous
variety of phenomena.
It's the physics of the ultra tiny,
but it goes well beyond that.
It explains why the Sunshine's,
it explains why we can
see that the sun shines a,
it is what almost every single piece of
technology in this room or in the world
runs on a,
it even explains why you're not sinking
through the chairs that you're sitting
in right now because quantum mechanics
explains why anything is ever solid.
Uh, so it's, it's just a phenomenally
successful theory. And, uh,
anybody who says otherwise is, you know,
has no idea what they're talking about.
It is a good theory,
but there is a problem.
The problem is that it is just not
clear what quantum physics is telling us
about the world around us.
The connection between the theory though
it's phenomenally successful and the
world that we're in is just not obvious.
And to explain what I mean by that,
say that I want to figure out
where this marker is. Right?
So right now if I want to use
Newton's physics, you know the,
the pre quantum classical physics
to figure out where this marker is,
I need three numbers to describe
where it is. I need to say, okay,
it's a certain height above the ground,
it's a certain distance in front of me
and it's a certain distance off to my
left.
But if I want to say where this
thing is in quantum mechanics,
if I want to describe its position,
I need more than three numbers.
I need an infinity of numbers
scattered across all of space.
And this is known as a wave
function. And this is, you know,
somewhat odd that we need an
infinity of numbers. But you know,
oddness is fine. The trouble with quantum
mechanics isn't that it's strange.
Strangeness Is Okay, the
World is a strange place. If
our theories weren't weird,
they wouldn't be able to
account for what we see. Uh,
the trouble is more complex than that.
See,
wave functions obey this very,
very nice equation called
the Schrodinger equation.
It's a really beautiful
differential equation.
It sort of smells like a law
of physics, right? It, uh,
it's, it's the quantum
mechanics equivalent of Newton's
second law. F equals m.
A. It's a good equation.
We like it. It's pretty,
it says that wave functions wave,
it says that the unusual late smoothly
and they don't make sudden changes.
They don't do anything. Well,
they do some surprising things,
but they don't make any
sudden moves. Um, but,
but the strange thing is
that wave functions don't
always obey the Schrodinger
equation.
Sometimes when we go and look for a thing,
the wave function of that thing suddenly
doesn't obey the Schrodinger equation
anymore. The Schrodinger equation
is temporarily suspended.
When we make a measurement and
instead the wave function collapses.
All those numbers scattered
across all of space.
They go to zero everywhere except in
the place where we found the object.
Now that's somewhat
strange, right? Like I said,
the Schrodinger equation
smells like a law of physics.
We don't expect the laws of physics to
get temporarily suspended when we make a
measurement. Uh, that's, that's just
odd. What's even otter is, it's,
it's kind of hard to define
what we mean by measurement.
What's a measurement?
It's a measurement.
When I measure the measurements
only when I measure,
why am I giving you a talk about quantum
mechanics where not only applies to me
a solid system isn't really a good look
on anybody and it's not a good look for
physics. Um, is it only when
humans measure? Now Einstein asked,
can a mouse collapse the wave function?
Uh,
that doesn't seem quite right either.
It seems like it shouldn't really have to,
anything to do with life or consciousness.
That's, that's not where we want to go.
And, and that doesn't really make the
idea of measurement less weird anyway.
Maybe it's when a big thing interacts
with this world of the ultra tiny,
the world of the quantum,
but there's no experimental evidence
that that's correct. And in fact,
there is a great deal of evidence that
suggests that quantum mechanics doesn't
have that kind of size limit.
So there's just a host of thorny
problems here about what we mean by
measurement. When wave functions
collapse, what prompts them to collapse?
What's going on here?
And this is given a special name,
it's called the measurement problem.
Now it's tempting to say that what's
really going on here is that the wave
function isn't a thing in the world.
It's just a measure of
probability in some way.
And that is the standard way of thinking
about wave functions is that they just
tell us the probability of finding
a thing in a particular spot.
And then you know, the idea of
collapse somewhat, you know,
it looks somewhat less strange
it because then you know, okay,
we don't know where it is.
And then we look and we find
it and now we know where it is.
And so the probability of it
being elsewhere has gone to zero.
And that's why wave functions collapse.
But it can't be quite that straightforward
because wave functions do some things
that we associate with physical waves
like water waves or sound waves or light
waves. Wave functions can actually
cause interference patterns to appear.
That's not something that we think of
mere probabilities as being able to do
that doesn't mean that it's not
probability. It just means that if it is,
it's not straight forward.
There has to be a more complicated story
here to explain what's going on and
there's also the question of,
okay,
so before we measure where is the object
that's described by this sort of spread
out wave function, where is the
marker before we look forward?
If it's way function is
scattered across all of space.
Now the standard answer here is to say
that it's not really in one place or
another.
It's,
it's in multiple places
at once and you know,
we don't see markers in more than
one place at once, but you know,
maybe subatomic particles,
maybe atoms and molecules can
perform that kind of trick.
But if we concede that, if we say,
yeah, that's definitely what's going on,
then we run into the most famous
version of the measurement pub problem,
which is Schrodinger's cat.
And you knew that this was coming.
It's a talk on quantum physics. So, uh,
Schrodinger put this together
in 1935 he said, okay,
say that you take a cat and a bunch of
equipment, you seal it inside of a box.
You can't see what's going on in there.
But what you've put in there with the
cat is a very weak radioactive source.
So lump of slightly radioactive metals,
and you've hooked it up to
a Geiger counter and the
Geiger counter detects that
radiation. And if it detects
radiation, it releases the hammer,
which smashes the vial of cyanide,
which kills the cat.
So of measurement is really
what collapses way functions.
Then the wave function of this whole
system shouldn't collapse until you open
the box.
In other words,
this piece of radiation that comes
out from the radioactive metal,
that's definitely a quantum
object. It's a small thing, right?
So it definitely obeys the laws of
quantum physics, which means that it's,
you know,
in this traditional way of thinking
about wave functions is probability.
It means that it's both been
released and remains in the metal,
which means that the Geiger counter
both goes off and doesn't go off,
which means that the hammer
falls and doesn't fall.
The cyanide is smashed and doesn't smash
and the cat is dead and alive until we
opened the box and
Schrodinger Yuri is said,
this is ridiculous.
You know,
maybe subatomic particles can be
in more than one place at once,
but cats are definitely not both
dead and alive until we open the box.
That just can't be right.
That doesn't make any sense.
And the fact that this is what the
theory seems to imply with the equation,
that by the way, guys, I
wrote down, that seems wrong,
right? That doesn't seem to be
the way that the world works.
And that doesn't mean that quantum physics
is wrong. It's definitely not wrong.
It's just not done yet. It's not complete.
Or there's something else beyond it.
And this shouldn't be controversial,
right?
The idea that our scientific theories
aren't the whole story. Yeah, sure.
There's going to be another theory.
You know,
nobody thinks that our scientific theories
that we have right now are the end of
the story. And that's all the
Schrodinger was trying to say.
He was saying there's something incomplete
here in our understanding of what's
going on in quantum physics,
but despite the fact that this seems
reasonable and straightforward,
most of Schrodinger's contemporaries
profoundly disagreed with him.
So people like Niels Bohr, uh,
or Verner, Heisenberg, Boris,
the guy on the left of that
picture from my perspective.
So I guess right from your perspective,
Heisenberg is the younger one on the
other side. So, um, Bohr and Heisenberg,
two of the other sort of
founders of quantum physics,
they profoundly disagree with
Schrodinger as did many of Schrodinger's
contemporaries. And many of the other
people who put together quantum physics,
they said, no, this is wrong.
This whole thing with the cat,
it's a misunderstanding. Some
of them said, yeah, you know,
it's just wrong to talk about what's
going on in the box before we open it.
Because what's going on in the box before
we look is in principle on observable.
And it's on the scientific to talk
about on observable things. In fact,
it's meaningless to talk about
unobservable things. This is,
this is the lesson of the philosophy
of language that comes out of quantum
physics. Others said, no, no, no, no,
no. It's not that. It's meaningless.
It's that opening the box really does
force the cat to be dead or alive.
And until we look, it really isn't either
one. Others said, no, no, no, no, no.
Quantum physics you've completely missed
supplied to this theory that you helped
develop.
Quantum physics has by necessity a split
between the measurer and the measured.
And the problem with the cat experiment
that you've set up is you're trying to
get rid of that division. And that's
what's leading to the confusion. Uh,
and others said, no. You know, you're,
you're trying to say that quantum
physics tells us how the world is.
Quantum physics isn't
about how the world is.
Quantum physics is just a tool that
we use to predict the outcomes of
measurements. That's all
it is. It's an instrument.
It's not a theory about
the state of the world.
And this collection of
vague related questionably,
coherent contradictory claims.
This is known as the
Copenhagen interpretation.
This named after the home of Neil
Spores Institute in Copenhagen,
which was the center of the physics world
for much of the first half of the 20th
century.
And the Copenhagen interpretation,
like I said,
this seems somewhat country contradictory.
It seems somewhat vague.
Uh, what does it have to say
about the measurement problem?
What does it say leaves to
wave function collapses?
What does it say is going on there?
How do we define what measurement is?
How do we say when wave
functions collapsed,
when does the Schrodinger equation
apply and when is it suspended?
The standard answer that the Copenhagen
interpretation gives to all of these
thorny questions at the heart of
the theory is somewhat unsatisfying.
Um, basically it says,
shut up and calculate. Um,
and, and this is not quite as foolish
as it first appears because again,
quantum physics works remarkably well.
It is incredibly good.
I can't stress this enough. I
mean quantum physics, uh, is,
is really responsible for most of the
technological breakthroughs of the last 90
years.
It is an incredibly good theory and
these questions at the heart of it really
seemed very thorny.
And so you have a choice of either
trying to bang your head against these
questions or you know,
contribute to one of the greatest
revolutions in the history of science
revolution that gave rise not only too
much of modern technology but much of
modern science.
I mean the whole field of genetics was
based on imaging breakthroughs that came
from quantum physics for example.
Um,
but shutting up in calculating,
saying all of these
things that the Copenhagen
interpretation wants to tell us,
it is unsatisfying. And I'll take
questions at the end. I really will.
This talk is not going to take the
whole time nowhere near. Um, uh,
but I, I'm excited to hear
your question. So, um, there,
there is a problem with shutting up and
calculate and there are several problems.
One problem is that, you know, we,
we want to understand what
is going on in the world.
Quantum physics tells
us why the sun shines.
But if quantum physics really is just
an instrument for predicting outcomes,
quantum physics doesn't
tell us why the sun shines.
It has no explanatory power at all.
It only has predictive power.
So it doesn't explain why I'm
not passing through the floor.
It doesn't explain why I can see. It
just says I won't pass through the floor.
It doesn't tell us where
those things come from.
It doesn't give us a picture of the world.
Uh,
and if that sounds a little bit wishy
washy, let me make it more clear.
Quantum physics, if the Copenhagen
interpretation is correct,
there's no reason why it's true.
There's no reason why it works. In fact,
its success is just a coincidence
because quantum physics,
according to the
Copenhagen interpretation,
isn't about anything in the world.
There's nothing in the world that is
even approximately described by the
equations of quantum physics. And if
that's true, why does the theory work?
What makes it true?
The fact that it works at all,
even though it has no connection
to anything in reality,
would be nothing short of a miracle,
a phenomenal coincidence if it's just
a trick for calculating that has no
relationship to the things in the
world around us. On top of that,
uh, there are some scientific projects
that we want to do as physicists,
which the Copenhagen interpretation
explicitly or implicitly makes very
difficult to impossible.
We want to think that measurement is a
physical process and physical processes
should be amenable to analysis.
We should be able to come up with a
physical theory of how measurement works,
but the Copenhagen interpretation
says, no, you can't do that.
There is no need or way to come up
with a quantum theory of measurement.
In fact,
Niels Bohr himself said that coming up
with the quantum theory of measurement
was fundamentally misguided as
a scientific project. We also,
and I mean this is near and
dear to my heart, this next one,
we want to be able to do cosmology.
We want to be able to study the
entire universe at once. Um,
but if we have to split the universe
into the measured and the measurer,
we can't do that.
And if we have to split the universe
into the measured and the measure,
we have an even bigger problem.
We want to account for classical physics,
the physics of Isaac Newton
using quantum physics.
That's why the theory was developed.
It was developed to explain situations
that we couldn't explain using classical
physics.
And yet if measurements are,
are a necessary part of the theory on
those measurements cannot be described
using quantum physics. They can only be
described using classical physics. Again,
as Niels Bohr and company said,
then we can't ground classical physics
in quantum physics. If anything,
it's the other way around.
The logical foundations of quantum
physics require classical physics.
And that seems really strange,
especially because there's
nothing particularly special
about classical physics.
You know, uh, Bohr and Heisenberg,
they said things like, oh,
the idea of measurement has to be grounded
in classical physics because that's
the way our intuitions work.
They read a lot of cons. Um,
and that's not true because classical
physics is profoundly counter intuitive.
Our intuitions are no more classical
than they are grounded in witchcraft or
astrology or classical physics
has many surprising results.
If you've ever done that thing where
you sit in a spinning chair and you hold
the bicycle wheel, I didn't see that
coming the first time they did that.
I don't think any of us do. So yeah,
that, that can't be right either.
So the Copenhagen interpretation
is profoundly unsatisfying
both scientifically
and philosophically.
Now it's time for a couple of disclaimers.
So here's the thing,
despite the fact that the Copenhagen
interpretation is unsatisfactory,
it is still the default interpretation.
It is the standard interpretation
of quantum physics today.
It is what is used in most popular
science books on the subject.
It is what is presented in basically
every single widely used quantum physics
textbook in undergraduate
and graduate courses.
I was exposed to it in that way as well.
Um,
it's what you learned in school.
It is what many,
if not most physicists believe to be
true and they believe this to hold the
answer to the measurement problem,
especially older physicist as
the Copenhagen interpretation
was once massively
overwhelmingly dominant. It's dominance
has declined over the last few decades.
So the first disclaimer is what I
just told you is a minority view.
I am in the minority. What I
just told you is not, you know,
the standard story that you
get in a quantum physics class.
So given that this is a minority view,
why am I so sure that I'm right?
Why am I so willing to
come up here to Google?
And other places have been giving
this talk and say, yeah, no,
the Copenhagen interpretation
doesn't work. Well,
there is definitely some controversy
over the foundations of quantum physics
among physicists,
but the history and
philosophy of quantum physics,
that's a different story.
In broad strokes,
there is an understanding of what
happened over the last 90 years and the
development of quantum physics and the
philosophy underpinning the stories that
we tell about quantum physics and that
history and philosophy is wildly unknown
to most physicists.
Physicists have a set of historical
and philosophical myths that they tell
amongst themselves,
kind of folk history that's passed
down from generation to generation of
physicists, either explicitly
or implicitly about the
history of quantum physics.
And why we believe the things that
we're told to believe about it,
that folk history is very wrong.
It is just as a matter of
historical fact incorrect.
And I'm going to explain to you what that
folk history is and then tell you what
actually happened.
Which leads me to my second disclaimer,
which is that the best psych research
suggests that if you're trying to debunk a
myth, you shouldn't
repeat the myth first. Um,
I'm gonna throw caution to
the wind and tell you this.
Folk history, this completely mythical
account of the history of quantum physics.
And then I'm going to
tell you why it's wrong.
So with all the stuff that
I'm about to tell you,
take it with a grain of salt.
So here we go.
Once upon a time,
there was a group of phenomenally
talented physicists, uh,
working in a loose team in the first
quarter of the 20th century to try to
understand what was going on
in the world of the ultra tiny,
the world of atoms and
subatomic particles. Now,
this team didn't have a leader per se,
but they had a kind of spiritual guide in
their request. And that was Niels Bohr,
who again, is, he's the older guy in
the picture over off on the side. Um,
and this team also included phenomenally
talented physicists like Verner
Heisenberg in the Middle Paoli
sitting across from Bor. Um,
and many other physicists be besides,
you know, Erwin Schrodinger, her, uh,
Louis boy, uh, a wide
collection of physicists.
And over the course of the first
quarter of the 20th century,
they developed the first real
theories of quantum mechanics.
And with these theories came a single
unified picture of how to think about
quantum mechanics called the
Copenhagen interpretation.
And the Copenhagen interpretation said
questions about what's happening before
you look at quantum
objects are meaningless.
It's not sensical to
even ask those questions.
The world is fundamentally random and
quantum mechanics is the best theory that
we can come up with to understand
what's going on in the quantum world.
And this really bothered Albert Einstein.
Most physicists were very happy
to accept this, but Einstein,
Einstein had once been a bomb throwing
revolutionary in his youth. He had,
he had blown up the physics world with
special relativity and then 10 years
later, general relativity.
But that was long ago. Uh,
now he was old. He was stuck in
his ways. He was conservative,
and he couldn't accept that quantum
physics could be fundamentally random.
He couldn't accept that the
world wasn't deterministic.
He was sure that the theory had
to be self contradictory or if not
contradictory, incomplete or
wrong in some fundamental way,
because determinism had to be
true according to Einstein.
So he developed a set of
thought experiments intended
to show that the theory
was contradictory.
And in particular he went after this
thing called the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle.
And the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
says that you can't know both the
position and the velocity,
the moment really the momentum,
but whatever the position and the
momentum of an object at the same time too
arbitrary precision.
He came up with a bunch of
thought experiments to try
to show that this wasn't
true,
but bore and bores team of researchers
showed at every turn that Einstein was
incorrect,
that he had misunderstood things and
this culminated in a thought experiment
where Einstein devised a box filled
with light that was hanging on a scale
spring with a clock attached to it and
a little door in the side and he showed
that you could use this to get around a
different uncertainty relationship and
quantum physics, the energy
time, uncertainty relation,
but bore took a look at this thing and
prove that Einstein was wrong for an
incredibly embarrassing
reason. He said, Einstein,
you forgotten your own
theory of general relativity,
which shows that this cannot work.
You cannot use this device to
get around the energy time,
uncertainty relationship.
Einstein, of course,
was incredibly embarrassed and he laid
low for a while and then he came up with
a new thought experiment that was going
to show the world that quantum physics
couldn't be correct.
And so he came up with something called
the EPR thought experiment named after
Einstein and his two coauthors on the
paper Podolsky and Rosen and the EPR paper
showed that you had to be able to
get around the uncertainty principle.
And if you couldn't,
that would mean that either quantum
physics was incomplete or that there was
something going faster than light.
Somehow Bor responded to this.
You know,
Einstein said nothing could
possibly be going faster than light.
That would be spooky. Action at a
distance board gave a response, you know,
brilliantly dismissing Einstein's
concerns. Most physicists thought, okay,
you know,
that's the end of it.
We still don't quite know which
one could be right, but you know,
it's a matter of philosophy.
We don't need to think about that.
And then 30 years later,
after both Bohr and Einstein were dead,
a physicist named John Bell came along
and he proved that Bora was right.
And Einstein was wrong,
and that you could not have some more
complete theory of how quantum physics
works without violating the
predictions of quantum physics.
And thus the world was made
safe for quantum physics
and everybody lived happily
ever after. So how much of
what I just told you is true?
Not a whole lot.
Most of that is just wrong.
As a matter of historical fact,
if you look at contemporary evidence,
you know letters that people sent to
each other lecture notes rather than
looking at,
you know,
people's recollections of what
happened years after the fact.
Here's what actually happened.
It is true that Bohr and Heisenberg
and Paoli and a group of brilliant
physicists did put together the first
true theories of quantum physics.
It is true that Einstein was among them
and that Einstein didn't like the theory.
Einstein though,
when these debates between him and
board started in the mid to late 1920s,
he, um, he was in his forties.
He wasn't exactly old and senile.
He was in perfectly good shape.
And his main concern actually had
nothing to do with the fact that quantum
physics presented a world that was,
you know,
fundamentally random.
He had two major concerns aside from
that one that was like a secondary or
tertiary concern.
He was concerned that quantum physics
didn't give us a real picture of the world
independent of observation.
So he's concerned about realism and he
was also concerned and he felt that these
were two sides of the same coin, that
because quantum physics was not relist,
it was also doomed to have nonlocality
spooky action at a distance.
Things influencing,
influencing each other at a distance
faster than the speed of light.
Instantaneously. Even nine sign
felt that that couldn't be right.
Not only because it
would violate relativity,
but because he felt it would make
it near impossible to do science.
And he thought the Copenhagen
interpretation was not only not realist,
but in so far as it was relist,
it was nonlocal and
that he could not abide.
And so he came up with a series of
thought experiments not to get around the
uncertainty principles.
Mostly he had one or two like that.
Mostly his thought experiments
were intended to show
that quantum physics was a
local.
This one was meant to show that
quantum physics was nonlocal.
It had nothing to do with the energy,
time on certainty relationship aside
from the fact that it did enter into the
setup in a way, but Einstein wasn't
trying to get around it any way.
Bor completely misunderstood what Einstein
was trying to get at with this setup.
He thought Einstein was trying
to get around the energy,
time on certainty relationship,
and thus show that quantum physics was
inconsistent internally and then in order
to answer this supposedly
argument from Einstein.
Bohr brought in a totally separate theory
that we still don't know how to make
consistent with quantum physics in order
to defend the internal consistency of
quantum physics.
In other words,
he gave a profoundly inadequate
argument in response to an argument that
Einstein wasn't even making.
This should have been a massive
embarrassment for Neil Spore
and the standard story around this.
This thought experiment is
just completely confused.
Einstein, meanwhile went home
and thought, you know, Shit,
boar still doesn't understand
what I'm getting at.
Let me make it simpler for him.
Thus was born the EPR thought experiment.
And so after more debates
between Einstein and Bohr,
Einstein put together
this thought experiment,
the EPR thought experiment. He published
it with his friends, collaborators,
Podolsky and Rosen.
And after it came out,
he actually wasn't that happy with the
way that the paper was put together,
but he then wrote about it more in both
letters and essays through the rest of
his life.
Um,
and he made it very clear that the
point of this thing was that there was a
forced choice.
There was a choice for quantum physics.
It could either be incomplete and
local or complete and nonlocal.
So he was saying if the
Copenhagen interpretation is
really the end of the story
than something has to be
going faster than light
or gave a response to the APR paper.
It was really, really hard to understand
what bores response was saying.
And I'm not just saying that because I've
read it and it makes no frigging sense.
I'm saying that because Boris said it did.
It was hard to understand.
[inaudible] actually wrote
about this about 15 years later,
he wrote about these debates that
he had with Einstein completely
mischaracterized them, and then
when he got to that part, he said,
I responded to the EPR paper. I apologize
for being so difficult to understand,
and then he moved on. He didn't actually
explain what he meant. He just said,
I know it was hard to understand,
and then he moved on. Nonetheless,
despite the fact that bore his writing
was sort of convoluted in obscure people
felt that these deep philosophical
puzzles at the heard of the theory,
we're actually better addressed
by convoluted, obscure writing.
That may be answers unclear rather than
Einstein's very clear direct writing.
That made it obvious that
there was a problem here.
Part of that was because you know
this confusion between obscurity and
profundity,
part of it was that bore worked
collaboratively with a group of people
throughout his entire life and so
he had more people just on his side
politically. Whereas Einstein, with
someone who usually worked alone,
Einstein described himself as going
through life like a one horse cart.
He did not really work with people.
He didn't build a school
of thought around himself,
and part of it was just an Einstein
was making very uncomfortable argument.
Einstein was saying, no, we're not
done. There's more work to be done here.
Whereas board was saying, no, it's cool.
Let's go off and keep doing
what we've been doing.
You don't have to worry about this. You
can just shut up and calculate. Now,
part of the reason that board won the
day was also that there was a proof by
John von Neumann that had been published
in 1932 saying that there was no way to
come up with a more complete theory
of quantum physics that you couldn't,
you know, add something to the theory
and thus get, you know, something,
not statistical,
something that that gives
you more complete picture
of reality without actually
changing the predictions of the
theory and nobody, not even Einstein,
wanted to change the predictions
of the theory because the theory is
phenomenally successful.
So von Neumann's proof and bores writings
sort of helped quantum physics carry
along. Now, there was
just one problem. Von Noi,
I'm in one of the greatest mathematicians
to have ever lived. Made a mistake,
has proof was wrong. This was actually
pointed out by the mathematician,
Gretta Herman only a few years later.
But people didn't listen to her probably
in part because she was a woman. Uh,
and in the 1930s women we're usually not
even allowed to teach at universities,
much less proof John von Neumann wrong.
Um,
so quantum physics just sort
carrying on with a whole lot.
It's hard piling success upon success
over the course of the Manhattan project
and World War Two,
which incidentally after the Manhattan
project and all that money poured into
physics classroom sizes ballooned
and the historian of physics,
David Kaiser at Mit has done a fascinating
study showing that the amount of time
devoted to foundational questions
in quantum physics in you know,
course syllabi after World War II is
inversely proportional to classroom size.
So the larger the classroom,
the less time they spend talking about
these questions at the heart of quantum
physics, which makes some sense,
it's hard to address them properly.
So after the war,
young physicist named David Boehme came
up with a different way of thinking
about quantum physics.
He discovered that you could just take
the equations as they were and develop an
entirely different picture of
nature to go along with it.
One that involved waves and particles
and was entirely deterministic in
particular.
It involves particles,
sort of surfing on waves and those
waves would guide the particles,
the waves could interfere with themselves
and with other waves and they would
guide the, you know, motion
of the particles to, you know,
appear in the correct locations as to
make the predictions of quantum physics
true. And this became
known as pilot wave theory.
But this was largely dismissed at the
time in part because of annoyance proof in
part because boars ideas had already
become entrenched over the quarter century
before that and part because
David Boehme had, um,
I'm going to go ahead and
call it shit luck. Uh,
David Boehme got really interested in
communism in the 1940s and then he got
called up before the House on
American Activities Committee, uh,
in the late 1940s chaired by,
um,
someone who probably haven't heard
of named Richard Nixon. And, um,
and then he got arrested on contempt of
Congress because he wouldn't name names
because he had, you
know, integrity. And, um,
and then he was cleared because it turns
out there is in fact a fifth amendment
of the United States constitution. Um,
but it didn't matter. He was blacklisted.
He was fired from his job at Princeton.
And in fact,
it was while he was waiting for his day
in court that he developed pilot wave
theory, um, which had, by the way,
part of it had been previously discovered
25 years earlier by Louis deploy. But,
um,
but Boehm sort of independently
rediscovered it and then
completed the theory.
But bomb was cleared on all charges.
But he was blacklisted at this,
happened right after he
submitted his papers, even
before they were published. Um,
couldn't find a job to work in physics
anywhere in the u s despite having
recommendation letters from Robert
Oppenheimer and Albert Einstein, um,
and ended up having to go to Brazil,
at which point his passport
was confiscated illegally
by the American Consulate.
And he was trapped in Brazil
for almost five years.
During which time his papers
were published, discussed
without him being around,
he could only corresponded a distance.
Many famous physicist's published papers
or gave talks explaining my bone was
wrong without bone being
there to defend himself.
And ultimately his ideas were
forgotten by most physicists,
but not all.
John Bell Read David Boams papers in 1952
when they were first published and he
immediately knew that something was wrong,
not with belts,
but not with bones papers.
He had been told of John von Neumann is
proof not have Gretta Hermanns, you know,
disproof of fond Nyman's proof
because nobody knew about that.
But he'd been told avant diamonds proof,
even though he had always
found the Copenhagen
interpretation hopelessly vague.
He said he knew it was a rotten,
um,
he figured there had
to be something better.
But then he was told about von diamonds
proof and figured, okay, you know,
I must just not be
understanding something.
And then he saw boams papers work
through them and realize, no,
there's nothing wrong with this. There
must be a flaw on this proof problem.
Bell didn't speak German.
The proof was only published in German.
He couldn't go in and figure out what
was wrong with it until it was published
in English a few years later, and by
then bell was busy with other things.
But in 1963,
bell came out to the South Bay,
actually.
He got invited to be a visitor for a year
while he was on sabbatical from cern.
He was a visitor at
slack just down the road.
And while he was at slack,
he figured, you know,
I really hate the Copenhagen
interpretation. It just can't be right.
And yet there's this proof from von
Neumann and these other proofs along the
same lines,
I know that they're wrong because there's
nothing wrong with bones version of
quantum physics.
And these proofs would rule it out.
Let me figure out what's wrong
with those proofs. So he sits down,
plays with them for awhile,
and he finds that von Neumann's
proof is not only broken.
He later characterized it as silly.
So he publishes a paper showing
that von Neumann is wrong,
which gets lost in an editor's
desk for a couple of years.
It was really unfortunate.
But then he says, okay,
but there's something else funny about
bones version of quantum physics.
It has this spooky action at a distance.
The position of a particle way over here
can instantaneously affect the behavior
of a pilot wave way over here
that that seems strange. You know,
is there a way not doing that?
Can I come up with something like bones
version of quantum physics without
having this instantaneous
action at a distance?
So he starts working on it and
he realizes he can't do it.
And then he writes up a proof and that
proof has become known as bell's Theorem.
Bell's Theorem is one of the single most
profound and important results in all
of quantum physics. It led to what's been
called the second quantum revolution,
which among other things led to the
entire field of quantum information
processing, quantum cryptography,
quantum computing, you name it. Um,
it's also profoundly misunderstood.
People often characterize bell's theorem.
Not only is proving that board was right,
but that proving that you can't have
anything like bones version of quantum
physics or they'll say,
oh,
it proves that either something is going
faster than light or you have hidden
variables completing the Theorem, you
know, completing quantum physics saying,
okay, you know, this is what's going on
before you look. That's not true. Uh,
in fact, uh, bell himself
said that that wasn't true.
That wasn't what the
proof was about at all.
It is pretty much just a proof
that nature is not local.
If it conforms with the
predictions of quantum physics.
There were only a couple of ways
out of that. One of them was, oh,
sorry, hold on. If you want to
learn more about bell's Theorem,
it is a whole subject
for a talk by itself.
I have an interactive essay explaining
it in more detail on my website. Um,
I'll leave that up there for a moment,
but there are only a few ways out of
belts near and people will sometimes say
that realism is a way
out of bell's Theorem.
That's actually not true either because
in order for realism to be a way out,
you would need to deny the existence of
an external reality to such an extent
that the idea of locality itself would
dissolve. So that's kind of nuts.
But another way out of Dallas
Theorem was developed, uh,
before bill did his work by a guy named
Hugh Everett who came up with what is
now known as the many worlds
interpretation of quantum physics. Uh,
which says that no, you know, wait,
functions don't collapse. Instead,
when you do Schrodinger's cat,
what happens is the radioactive metal
wave function gets mixed up with the wave
function of the Geiger counter
in the cyanide in the cat.
And so now instead of a piece of radiation
that's both in the metal and not in
the metal, you have a cat
that is both dead and alive.
And then when you opened the box,
you are wave function gets mixed up
with these other way functions as well.
And now there is a copy of you looking at
a dead cat in a box and sad and a copy.
If you're looking at a living
cat in a box and happy,
I guess that you didn't kill
a cat. Um, in any event,
this is another way out of bell's Theorem.
You can come up with a version of many
worlds that is local because bell's
theorem assumes that you
only have one universe,
but these are not the only
two options on the table.
There are many other interpretations
of quantum physics available.
It's just that the Copenhagen
interpretation isn't one of them.
There are other ways of doing this
and given that there are ways of
understanding what's
actually going on in nature,
just throwing up your hands and
saying, I give up, we can't do it.
There's no way to understand.
It seems both profoundly inadequate
and frankly unscientific.
But you may be left with another question,
a much,
much deeper and more profound question.
Who Cares if quantum physics works and
why does any of this matter and it does
work. As I've said over and over again,
quantum physics definitely works,
so why does it matter what it's
telling us about the world?
If we can use it to do whatever we want,
I'm going to need to appeal to
a higher authority on this one.
Now,
another thing that people often say is
that for getting two identical theories,
theory, theory, which
look completely different,
psychological,
different ideas in them and so on,
but then all the
consequences that a computer,
all the consequence of the
computer are exactly the same.
Maybe replay they even agree
with it's from the head.
The point is though that the two theories,
although they sound
different at the beginning,
have all kinds of quenches the same.
It's easier usually to
prove that mathematically by
doing a little mathematics
ahead of time to show that the logic from
this one and this one will always give
corresponding consequence.
Suppose we have two such theories.
How are we going to decide
which one is right? No Way.
Not by science because they both agree
with experiments. At the same extent.
There's no way to distinguish one from me.
So on two theories all alone and they
have dick deeply different ideas by them,
maybe mathematically identical and they
usually people say then in science when
should pay. One doesn't know how to
distinguish him and that's right. However,
for psychological reasons,
in order to get new theories,
these two things are very far from the
film because one gives a man different
ideas than the other. By putting the
theory in a certain kind of framework,
you get an idea of what the chain,
which would be something printed in
theory that talks about something.
But you say,
I'll change that idea here,
but to find out what the car is funding
thing is you're going to change in here.
Amazing, very complicated. It may
not be a simple idea. In other words,
just simple change here makes maybe a
very different theories and a simple
change there. In other words, all
they are identical before that change.
There are certain ways of
changing one which looked natural,
which not look natural,
and then the other.
Therefore psychologically we
must keep all the theories.
And I had and every theoretical
physicists, it's any good. No.
It was six or seven different theoretical
representations for exactly the same
physics and our knows that the tooth that
they're all equivalent and that nobody
is ever going to be able to decide
which one is right at that level,
but he keeps him in his head hoping that
they'll give them different ideas for
guests. It's a valley. That reminds
me of another thing that is,
that's the philosophy or
the ideas around the theory.
A lot of ideas you say,
I believe there are,
there is a space of time or something
like that in order to discuss your
analysis at these ideas change enormously
when they were very tiny changes in
the theory. In other words, sprinters,
Newton's ideas about space and time
agreeing with experiment very well,
but in order to get the correct
motion of the orbit of mercury,
which was a tiny,
tiny difference.
There's a difference in the character
of the theory with which you started was
enormous.
Reason is these are so simple and so
perfect that produce definite results in.
If they get something that produced
a little different results could be
completely different. You can't make
imperfections on appropriate thing.
I have another sort of philosophical
ideas between Newton's theory of
gravitation and Einstein's theory
of gravitation are enormous.
Differences rather are enormous. What are
these philosophies? These philosophies,
I really freaky why? He used to compute
consequences quickly. Our philosophy,
which is sometimes called
an understanding of the law,
is simply a way that a person holds the
laws in his mind was the guest quickly a
consequences. Some people have
said, and it's true, for instance,
in the case of Maxwell's equations and
other equations, nevermind the philosophy,
nevermind anything of this
kind just guessed the crate.
The problem is only to compute the answer
so that I agree with experiment and
there's not necessarily to have a
philosophy or argue or worries about the
equation. That's true
in a sense. Yes, I know.
It's good in the sense that you may be,
if you only get the equation,
you're not prejudice in yourself and your
guests better and the other hand maybe
the philosophy helps you to get.
It's very hard to say
for those people who insist,
however,
that the only thing that's important is
that the theory agrees with experiment.
I would like to make an imaginary
discussion between a Mayan astronomer as
students. The Mayans were
able to calculate with great
precision, great precision.
The predictions,
for example,
three eclipses and the position
of the moon in the sky,
a position of Venus and side.
However,
it was all done by a the counter certain
numbers or subtract some numbers and
song. There was no discussion
of what the moon was.
There wasn't even a discussion
of the idea that it went around.
There was only calculate the time when
there would be an eclipse or the time
when it would rise.
They're full moon and when it would rise,
have one saw and just calculated only
supposedly the young man going to the
astronomy and said, I have an idea.
Maybe those things are going around,
and then a balls of locks
was like rocks out there.
We could calculate how they move and
a completely different way and just
calculate what time they appeared,
the scarring.
So the of course the Miami
[inaudible] would say yes.
How accurate could you predict eclipses?
You said,
I haven't developed a thing very far.
This is,
but we can calculate equipped is more
likely than you can with your model.
And so you must not pay any attention
to there's the mathematical scheme is
better.
And it was very strong tendency of people
to say against some idea if someone
comes up with an idea,
so let's suppose the world was
this way and you say to them,
well how would you get,
what would you get for the answer for
such and such a problem? And he says,
I haven't developed it far
enough. And you say, wow,
we have already developed
that much further.
We can get the answers very accurately.
So it is a problem as to whether or
not to worry about philosophies behind
ideas.
So it's certainly true that you can
use whatever interpretation of quantum
physics you like and come up
with the same predictions.
And given that there is no test
that you can perform to show which
interpretation of quantum
physics is correct,
but the story of the world that goes
along with the theories that we have in
science plays a big role in
the actual practice of science.
It actually influences the way that we
come up with new theories to go beyond
the current theory. It influences, um,
what experiments we conduct and it
influences how we interpret the results of
those experiments.
Fiman gives an example of a,
and this is in by the way, his
book, the character of physical law,
which is a compilation of the lectures
that I was going to play a clip from. Um,
Fineman,
uh,
gives the example of someone going
to a Mayan astronomer, you know,
back when the Mayan civilization was at
its peak. Uh, and saying, look, you know,
I know we have this theory that says that,
um,
that that allows us to
predict when it clips,
this will happen and when
Venus will transmit the sun
and all these other things
to phenomenal precision.
But the theory doesn't tell us
what Venus is or what the moon is.
I have a theory that tells us all
those things and it, and it, uh, and,
and then the Mayan astronomer says,
okay,
but can you do the same things we can
do? And the other guy says, well, no,
I haven't developed it fully yet.
It doesn't mean that we shouldn't
listen to the other guy. Right.
And it doesn't mean that even if he could
get it to work just as well as my in
astronomy, that doesn't
mean that, you know,
there's no difference between the
choices we make in our theories.
It matters for the progress of science
and it matters beyond just the realm of
science as well. It matters
for the entire world. Remember,
throughout the history of humanity,
this was at least in Europe,
the dominant way of thinking about what
the universe looked like throughout most
of human history, the earth is at the
center and everything moves around us.
And it wasn't until Copernicus in the 15
hundreds that people started seriously
considering the possibility that the
earth is not at the center of everything.
And without that move, without
Copernicus on the centering the earth,
it seems unlikely that Darwin would
have had the audacity to say, yeah,
humans are not at the
center of creation either.
We're just another part
of a giant tree of life.
And without those two insights, our entire
modern world, not just science, book,
culture, art, movies, would
look entirely different.
Kubrick would never have been able to
film in 2001 not that that's, you know,
the pinnacle achievement of
humanity and the 20th century.
But I really like that movie. Uh, and, and
I think it's an important piece of art.
And there were other very important
pieces of art, science, religion,
politics,
economics,
all of the realms of human experience
and endeavor are effected by the stories
that we get from our science.
And in fact,
this is how we do every other piece
of science. You know, nobody says, oh,
genes aren't
real. They're just a way of explaining
the outcomes of electron microscope
observations and genetics experiments.
Nobody says,
or at least physicists usually
don't say spacetime isn't real.
It's just something that helps us
understand the outcomes at Lego.
We don't say electromagnetic
fields aren't real.
We're very willing to grant reality to
things except when it comes to quantum
physics and the reasons for
that are largely historical.
Um, I've written a book that
is about all of this. Uh,
there were copies of the back, but it
looks like everyone's snapped them up.
That's great. Uh, you
can buy it online. Um,
you can go find it anywhere.
Books are sold. Um,
and if you do that will make me
happy. I hope you enjoy it. Um,
you can get ahold of me relatively easily
if you want to ask me questions about
anything in there.
I discuss all of this in much greater
detail in the book and the book is like
this talk,
I hope,
understandable for people who
have no physics background at all.
The intended audience is just
the interested public. So, uh,
with that, thank you for
your time. Any questions?
Thanks.
I guess putting the historical, putting
things historically correct, uh,
Einstein has also attributed to this
quote of God doesn't play, you know,
it doesn't roll the die and, um, play
with the ice. And, uh, so you probably,
that might have also been taken
out of context, you know, if he,
if he actually didn't,
his biggest problems weren't with,
as you said that the randomness,
but yeah.
But more with this action at a distance.
It sounds like that quote was
also kind of out of context.
I think that's correct,
given that Einstein famously said that
God doesn't play dice with the universe.
Um,
you know,
it sounds like that was taken
out of context given that
his primary problem with
quantum physics was not
randomness. Um, I'm sorry, Alex,
can you take the computer and do
that? Sure. Yeah. Thank you. Um,
I can't actually go. Okay. That's fine.
Um, so yeah, I think that's right. It was,
it's not so much that it was taken
out of context as it is that it's not,
it was a real problem that he had.
He did not like the randomness
of quantum physics. Um,
he just also didn't like other things
about quantum physics even more.
I mean, he also said, you know,
I can't abide spooky action at a
distance that that got closer to his real
problem.
And he also said some very quotable things
about his problems with the, you know,
non realism of the Copenhagen
interpretation. Um,
they're just not as well
known. And I think that that's
largely because, you know,
the idea of God playing dice is, is
this very sort of sexy image. Um,
and also because, you know, it,
it conforms with this standard incorrect
narrative among physicists about the
history of physics. I'm like, you
know, Einstein also said, uh, and I,
I love this quote so
much. He said that, um,
regarding the Copenhagen interpretation
that it was a soft pillow, uh,
that, um, that, uh, the,
the true believer can rest his head on,
but it provides very little
comfort to him. Or he also
said that, you know, again,
regarding the Copenhagen interpretation
and its denial of reality,
he said that this epistemology
fueled orgy must come to an end.
Um, and I went and looked that
up thinking, you know, okay,
maybe the translation from the German
took a few liberties. It's right in there.
It's something like
epistemology or g. Uh, so yeah,
know Einstein was, was pretty
clear about what his problem was.
It's just not been represented properly.
Yeah.
Let's do, uh, um, on the online question
for okay. And then we can alternate. Yep.
Okay. Sounds good. So
what's the online question?
What are your thoughts on the
Conway Colin a freewill serum,
which basically says that there's a finite
set of experiments such that there is
no consistent set of possible
outcomes for all the experiments.
This is a question about my thoughts on
the Conway Coken freewill experiment.
It's a good question.
Uh,
I'm going to say something that will
probably piss off people in response.
The Conway cocaine freewill Theorem
is just an attempt to repackage bell's
theorem along with a different
result and known as contextuality,
which is actually also due to bell.
Uh,
it was bells demolition of von Nivens
proof that I talked about earlier. Um,
I don't think that there's anything in
there that is Indian, those two proofs.
And I think that mostly what it means
is that the area's nonlocality in nature
or something else. One of the other
ways out of bell's theorem must be true,
like multiple universes. Um, so yeah,
maybe not the most
interesting response to that,
but I actually don't find the
result terribly interesting either.
Okay.
So I find it very surprising this,
that are prominent physicists who don't
think that's what the mechanics is a
unitary or violate something,
uh, need mathematical properties.
It's an unlikeable. Uh,
so what words mean you,
you've had some interesting
discussions with Peter White's, uh,
I mean it's Sabine Hudson Felder's a
prominent blogger who doesn't believe in
the multiverse. Uh, uh,
so what did the shut up and
calculate people say happens, uh,
in the show there in gears,
cats scenario for some,
for a sufficiently small cat?
That's a good question.
Um, so first of all,
let me make it clear. I am not saying,
Oh, the multiverse is definitely true.
I am saying, I am saying, okay, good.
Yeah, no, it's a viable option, but, well,
some people don't seem to understand
that. That's what I'm saying. Um, I dunno.
I thought I'd made it pretty clear
in my book and in the dog, but um,
yeah,
I,
so you're asking what the Copenhagen
interpretation people say happens to the
cat? Schrodinger's cat for a
sufficiently small cat. Um,
that's an excellent question.
I am strongly tempted to give
a very glib answer and save.
They don't say what happens to the cat.
They don't say what happens to anything
because their interpretation is
profoundly anti realist. Um, if
I wanted to be more charitable,
I would say you have to pick a version
of the Copenhagen interpretation.
There is no single Copenhagen
interpretation and arguably it's not an
interpretation at all.
So it's,
the phrase of the Copenhagen
interpretation is a little
bit like the holy Roman
Empire. You know, there's, there's no the,
and there's no interpretation and
the affiliation with Copenhagen is
questionable. But, um, but if you, if you
pick a version of Copenhagen, if you say,
okay, let's pick the version that says
quantum mechanics stops applying at a
particular, you know, size scale,
then the answer of what happens
to the cat is reasonably clear.
If it's larger than that size scale
than the cat is either dead or alive.
And if it's smaller than the
cat is both dead and alive.
If you pick a version of
Copenhagen that says no,
it's meaningless to ask about what
happens to the cap before you look,
then the answer is we can't say what
happens to the cabinet until you look
because it's meaningless because that's
what we said because we don't understand
philosophy of language or metaphysics
because we didn't pay attention when the
logical positivists were taken down in the
mid 20th century. Um, but I definitely,
but then you can get an interference
pattern of cats. I agree. Yeah. No,
you can get an interference.
The interference pattern is real.
I can't defend it because they
think it's not just wrong,
but logically incoherent.
Um, which makes it very,
very difficult to be, you
know, sympathetic. I have
to pick a version of it.
And as far as I can tell,
the most reasonable version of Copenhagen,
which some people at least did believe
that some points is that there was some
sort of split between the
classical and the quantum.
It happens either at some scale or when
it hits the brain because the brain is
somehow exempt from the laws
of physics anyway. Yeah.
Like second under Tory
question first. Yeah. Oh, okay.
Um, freewill is bogus and the
world is entirely deterministic.
Does,
does contradict quantum physics.
What does it mean for
there to be no causation?
Um, okay. So the question is about whether
quantum physics is deterministic, uh,
and,
and what it or whether you know it,
what it would mean for there to be no
causation, whether quantum physics,
it's deterministic, depends on your
interpretation. Um, for example,
the pilot wave interpretation
is entirely deterministic.
The many worlds interpretation
is entirely deterministic,
which is actually kind of a problem for
it because you need to figure out where
the probabilities come from in
the pilot wave interpretation.
They come from ignorance and
the many worlds interpretation,
you need to figure out why we don't know
things because everything obeys this
totally deterministic
Schrodinger equation. Um,
but there are people who work on that
who thinks they found solutions to it.
It's an active area of
research. Um, nonetheless,
that's totally deterministic.
Um,
there are proposed modifications
to quantum mechanics
that would also solve the
measurement problem called
spontaneous collapse theories.
Those are fundamentally non-deterministic.
So it depends on what you pick.
Um, as for what it means for
things to not be deterministic,
it means that sometimes the future of
the world is not fully specified by the
past state of the world.
Uh, an effort to figure out the nature of
the universe and how the universe works
until or unless it can come up with
some kind of device that can measure or
detect that which energy
and mass actually is.
Because when you tear
apart both mass and energy,
eventually you're left with nothing.
But obviously mass and energy
must be coming from something.
Do you think we'll ever
come up with some means
made up of mass or energy that can detect
that which underlies mass and energy?
Do you think that's ever possible?
Um, I think that math is
just one form of energy.
I wouldn't say that mass and energy
are two sides of the same coin.
I would say maths is just one kind of
energy. And what's fundamental is energy.
And that is the standard
view among most physicists.
And I think it's probably right,
mass as it kind of energy the same way.
Kinetic energy. Is it kind of energy
the same way he does it kind of? Well,
he doesn't kind of kinetic energy.
Um,
the same with the potential energy is a
kind of energy. Um, I, I think that, um,
what equals MC squared really says
is that mass is form of energy. Um,
so yeah, I, I, I don't see a problem
there the way that you do. Okay.
Yup. You, uh,
let's go back to the story.
What is consciousness?
According to quantum physics,
I don't see a relationship. I, okay,
let me be less flip.
Um,
so I think that a lot of people like
to say that consciousness has some
relationship to quantum physics
because we don't fully understand what
consciousness is and because there's
controversy over the solution to the
measurement problem.
So if we put together the two
things that we don't understand,
maybe we'll get just one thing
we don't understand. Um, and,
and some serious physicists have at
various points proposed that consciousness
is the solution to the
measurement problem.
That it's consciousness that
collapses wave functions. Uh,
Eugene Vegner believe this at one
point until he was set straight. Um, I,
I don't think that that's correct.
I think that if that is correct,
we need to do a lot more work to prove
that it's correct because there are
definitely viable alternatives
to that on the table. Um,
I think that if consciousness causes
collapse, we have questions like, okay,
what is consciousness, uh, by what
virtue is, does it cause collapse?
What property does it have that
allows it to collapse wave functions?
What else can collapse wave functions?
It's, it's a whole host of other problems.
Uh, and I don't think quantum physics
itself says anything about the nature of
consciousness. I think that
that's, uh, what consciousness is,
is a good question for a different field.
So,
so I remember reading like 30 years ago
these books, uh, following up to that,
the dancing really masters
and the Dell of consciousness.
And I think the whole premise of those
books was what can cause a collapse in,
in the, in these functions. Is
that, is that basically the whole,
that was the whole misconception of
those books that they based their entire
farm worker owned. The question was,
um, and, and can I ask you a followup?
Which is it, while you're, what,
what does cause a collapse?
What can cause a collapse
in, in this funk? Sure. Okay.
So first I realized I'd never actually
repeated the original question I just
answered, which was what is consciousness
according to quantum physics?
That's the answer you just gave.
Your question was these books,
the dancing really masters,
the Tao of physics,
was this about a misunderstanding of
what causes the collapse of the wave
function and then what does cause
the collapse of the wave function?
I think that those books were,
and did full disclaimer,
I have not actually read both of
those books from cover to cover.
I flipped through them. But, um,
I think that part of the deal with those
books is that they are interested in
going after these questions that were
seen as verboten for physicists by the
Copenhagen interpretation,
which, you know,
the shut up part of shut up and calculate
has this sort of moralistic sense to
it.
Like not only should you not ask that,
not only don't you need
to ask these questions,
you shouldn't ask these questions. Good
physicists, don't ask these questions.
There's something wrong with you
if you ask these questions. Um,
which is bullshit.
Um,
but I think that these books were
motivated in part by a desire to ask those
questions and then they said,
okay,
and let's ask other questions that are
verboten to physicists. Like, you know,
is their ESP. What about, you
know, telekinesis, you know,
what about the relationship between
religion and quantum physics consciousness
and quantum physics.
And I think, you know,
throwing and all that stuff
really confuses things. Um,
but I think that they were right to ask
the question of what's going on wave
function, collapse. Um,
I also think that they were motivated by
this sort of desire to see similarities
between certain religions and,
you know, quantum physics.
Uh,
and just to,
to talk about that for a second before
I get to your last part of the question.
Um,
I think it's generally a bad idea to try
to find parallels between religion and
science because science has
this nasty habit of, you know,
being refined and corrected and improve,
you know,
wrong or scientific
theories get overturned.
So if you try to latch your religious
philosophy onto a particular scientific
truth,
there's a good chance that your religious
philosophy is going to go down the
toilet when that truth is found to be
not quite true or completely wrong. Um,
so I,
I'm not very sympathetic to that project
and I don't think that people who like
religion should be either, um, anyway. Um,
as for what actually causes the
collapse of the wave function, I dunno,
I don't even know if wave functions
do collapse if they don't collapse.
We live in many worlds or we have
something like pilot wave theory where
collapses
not it's,
it's something that's sort of
relative to other stuff. It's,
it's more complicated than that.
Or we have something like a spontaneous
collapse theory where collapse is a real
objective thing that happens at random.
Um,
we're one of the other options
so I don't know what causes it,
but either wave function
collapses happening or
something is causing it to look
like wave function collapses happening
and figuring out what's going on.
There is a legitimate area
of scientific inquiry, uh,
called foundations of quantum physics.
Um,
that still has a bad reputation among
physicists. Even to this day though,
it's less bad than it used to be.
You mentioned, um, I, I've heard
you mentioned many times that um,
there's sort of this big split between,
um,
physicists and philosophers of physics
because physicists don't know any
philosophy yup. While philosophers of
physics, no, a lot of physics. Yes.
Uh, I'm, I'm also thinking of, I think I'm
probably going to misquote it, quote by,
uh, I think it might be some modern
philosopher, might be Dan Dennett.
I Dunno who said something like, you know,
there's no science without philosophy.
There's only science wit unexamined
philosophy or something like that,
which I'll play something
then it would say. And so I,
I thought maybe you might
want to comment on like,
why is it that physicist during the,
when he philosophy anymore, at least
there's a very good question.
So the question is about why physicists
mostly don't seem to know philosophy,
but philosophers of physics,
you know,
the serious ones tend to be
very well schooled in physics.
Many of them have undergraduate or even
PhDs in philosophy or in physics as well
as philosophy. Um, yeah,
there's definitely an asymmetry there
where the philosophers know much more
physics than the physicists know
philosophy. Um, as a physicist,
I'm interested in asymmetries.
Um, so yeah, I think,
uh, I think that, um,
basically this is,
this is due to a variety of
historical and cultural factors.
Um, I think that, I think that that quote,
whether it's Dan Dennett or
whoever who said that, uh,
it's definitely true that physicists
engage in philosophy all the time while
doing philosophy or while doing
physics. It's just part of it. Um,
and, and then the question is, okay,
you know, why don't they admit that?
Why don't they look at this?
Well,
philosophy has a bit of a bad
reputation among physicists,
so why does it have a bad reputation?
That's a hard question to answer.
I think part of it has to do with those
same factors at work after World War II
where academia and just got flooded with
more people and this led to a sort of
balkanization of academia and the walls
kind of went up between departments.
It used to be that physicists generally
had some schooling in philosophy.
Now that's not necessary. I'm
not saying that, you know,
we should go back to the good
old days are plenty of problems,
but I do think that a liberal arts
education is quite valuable, uh,
for doing almost anything.
Um,
but I think that due to that,
you know,
that sort of set of boundaries between
academic disciplines that has made it
easy for physicists to be
ignorant of philosophy.
And then it's easy for
misconceptions about philosophy.
Like it doesn't make progress.
They just asked the same
questions over and over again.
They're not like us physicists, you know,
uh, that, that kind of thing to show up.
Um, philosophers also have a habit
of asking very annoying questions.
This is a long and proud tradition
going back to Socrates. Um,
though most of us don't have to, you know,
drink hemlock as a result. Um, but, uh,
you know,
one way of dismissing annoying questions
is to say that the people who ask the
knowing questions are stupid and don't
need to be listened to, you know,
or you make them drink hemlock.
So, um, but that's, that's,
that's another thing. Um, I think that
there are some philosophers who are,
let's say, skeptical of
scientific progress. Um,
this has to do with a split
within philosophy between
analytic and continental
philosophy,
which is a whole other thing.
And those names are incidentally
not relevant at all to
what those fields study.
They're just historical artifacts. Um,
but continental philosophy tends to,
you know, um, be a little bit more
skeptical of authority in any form and,
and in many ways, rightly so. Uh,
and it tends to ask questions
about scientific authority,
which if you interpret them naively or
figure a bad continental philosopher can
lead to people saying things like,
Oh,
science is just as good as any other way
of, you know, trying to solve problems.
And that's some bullshit and scientist
who'd be rightly dismissive of that.
And then they might lump all
other philosophers and with that.
But that's just a guess on my part.
Um,
so I think that basically philosophy has
a very bad reputation for a variety of
reasons. Um, it used to not, um,
you know, uh, boarded, read
too much content, but it's
better than reading nothing.
Um, Einstein read a lot of
Ma and Leiden. It's and, uh,
and uh,
Espinosa and other great philosophers.
Hume in particular.
Um, yeah, I think that,
um, I think we have, it's a real
shame that that asymmetry is there.
I think that philosophers of physics
have a lot to teach physicists and,
and have a lot of value to offer.
Um,
and I think it's really awful
when prominent scientists, um,
say stupid things about philosophy,
which happens more often than it should.
So the next question is,
what about the success of Quantum
electrodynamics and predicting? Um,
I mean, it seems like your answer
is the past hour long talk, roughly.
Yeah. So, so the, the, the success of
quantum electrodynamics yeah, absolutely.
Quantum electrodynamics and quantum
field theories in general are extremely
successful on not debating the success
of quantum physics. It absolutely works.
It's just an incomplete picture of what's
going on in the world and throwing in
quantum field theory as opposed to just,
you know,
Vanilla quantum mechanics doesn't fix the
problem. If anything, it makes it worse.
You know, uh, some people will say, Oh,
quantum field theory definitely gets you
around bell's Theorem because quantum
field theories designed to be
compatible with special relativity. Uh,
there are these things called
the Comutation relations that,
that sort of ensure this,
um, relationship. Uh, no,
that doesn't solve the problem at all
because you still have the problem of wave
function collapse in quantum field theory
and that is subject to bell's Theorem
and that does not get solved
by the Comutation relations.
And this is a massive misunderstanding
that still persist among physicists.
And that's just a mathematical mistake.
That's just an error.
Quantum field theory
doesn't solve this problem.
A quantum field theory also has other
problems. It works incredibly well,
but it also has its own
unique issues, you know, that,
that mathematicians worry about like
renormalization or something called hugs
theory in which don't get me
started. Um, yeah. Uh, anyway,
so yeah, I mean quantum field
theory is great. I love it. Uh,
it is a wonderful theory. It
doesn't solve these problems. Okay.
We have time for one more question.
So I think since you haven't had time,
just follow up to your previous answer,
um,
s without speculating about why this
is to have a bad image of philosophy.
Can you, from your research
pinpoint when this attitude,
like when did [inaudible] start to have
a bad image of philosophy and since
you're a physicist and philosopher,
yeah.
Can you give us your
attitude towards philosophy,
noting that your answer
doesn't need to be monolithic.
Is there some part of philosophy that
you think is, was worth worthwhile?
I don't know exactly
when the split happened.
I don't think it's something
that happened all at once.
I think that World War II has a lot
to do with it, which is, you know,
in a way kind of boring answer,
you know,
and like one of the central events of
the 20th century had a lot of effects.
You know, that's, that's a somewhat boring
answer, but, um, but yeah, I mean we're,
we're two really changed
the way that academia works.
It really moved the center of
physics from Germany to the US,
the US already habit tradition of much
more pragmatic approaches to the sciences,
um, which, you know, uh, that's going to
make philosophy look yes, less useful.
Um, there was also this school of
thought called logical positivism,
which was very influential in the
first half of the 20th century.
And then, uh, and it was
also a school of thought,
which was dismissive of
certain kinds of philosophy.
And then around the time that physics
and philosophy kind of decoupled around
the end of World War Two,
that was also the beginning of
the decline of logical positivism,
even among philosophers
who were sympathetic to the
aims of the positivists.
And so by the time positivism was
sort of fully discredited, um,
this asis couldn't really get the memo
and still use a lot of positivist aish
arguments, really knockoff
positivist arguments like, oh,
it's meaningless to talk about
things that you can't see. The,
would use those arguments to dismiss most
of philosophy when in fact philosophy
is it, you know, decades old
counter arguments explaining
why that doesn't work.
And when you present those to physicists,
they will sort of the sort of stare at
you slack jawed like, wow, how did you,
you know, did you come up
with that yourself? That
seems very profound and think,
know that argument is older than
both of us combined. Um, so,
um, so yeah, as for my take on philosophy,
I think that in general it is usually a
bad idea to dismiss almost any area of
serious academic inquiry. There
are exceptions, um, such as,
you know, evolutionary
psychology. But, um,
uh, but, but, uh, um, I like
psychology, evolutionary psychology.
Um, um, but, uh,
but I think that most of philosophy
has something worthwhile.
I think philosophy of physics in,
in the analytic tradition has done a
lot of really great work in particular
because it's gone after these questions
that physicists have largely ignored. Um,
but I also think that,
you know,
philosophy of science really helps to
clear up a lot of misunderstandings that
are prom, like prevalent among scientists
of all stripes about how science works.
There are some naive ideas there that
philosophers have helped to sort of kick
to the curb. Um, I think that,
I think that if you think that you
have a simple answer to a deep question
talking to a philosopher
for a few minutes,
it will usually tell you that
you're wrong. And I think that,
that it's good to experience being wrong.
I think depends on an important
part of the human experience.
And I think that it's good to think
deeply about strange questions.
Um, and I think that the questions
philosophers tend to ask,
and this might be another sore
like source of the problem,
philosophers will ask questions that
sound like they have obvious answers to
scientists. Like, okay, you
know, um, what is a physical law?
Okay. You know that that
doesn't seem interesting and
it seems obvious. And then,
you know, they go on about it for five
minutes and I go, okay, you know, yeah,
I see what they're asking,
but I think there's an easy answer.
And then they go on about it for 10 more
minutes and you realize you don't even
know where the hell you are
anymore. Um, and I mean,
I think that that's a really
good experience to have.
I think it's good to understand,
wait,
these things that we take for granted
might be way more complicated than we
think.
And there is also a long and proud
tradition in science of doing science and
damn the torpedoes, you
know, forget, you know,
the philosophical or
mathematical foundations.
I'm not even saying that shut up and
calculate was always the wrong approach.
It's certainly not the case that every
single physicist should be thinking about
quantum foundations all the time. It's
just that moralistic thing of, no,
you should shut up and calculate.
A good physicist shuts up and calculates.
That's some bullshit. You know, the,
these questions are
legitimate parts of science,
and the boundary between
science and philosophy is,
and always has been permeable, um, just
as it is between any two disciplines.
And, um, yeah, it's been a
pleasure and thank you, all
of you for coming. Thank you.
[inaudible].